[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
Joker I really didn't know who I was
gonna go see this one I had mixed
thoughts on the trailer it looked like
there was some interesting ideas at the
heart of it but I really questioned
whether or not it could be pulled off
what it appeared the thing seemed to be
trying to do I'll try not to have this
overly tanked the review but like it's
in my head so I be remiss to not mention
it some of the stuff Todd Phillips the
director has said recently on the record
about his mentality and how he
approached this thing rubbed me the
wrong way and I was I'm not gonna say it
was like I was gonna make the decision
to not see it but I was kind of prepared
like if it if it hadn't landed with a
bigger splash than it did I would have
been prepared to just kind of not go out
of my way to get to it but it is in a
lot of conversations right now or at
least you know within the spheres that I
keep tabs on it seems to be on a lot of
people's minds a lot of conversations
going on seems to be pretty divisive in
some specific ways and it felt wrong not
to see the thing try and take it on its
own terms and its own merits and have my
own dang opinion about it
so Joker is it good parts of it did I
enjoy it
not really but part of that is
due to just my own man tell me what I
like or don't like in film in general
there are just some things that I was
never going to like about this film that
aren't necessarily false in the film I
think a good example of that is there's
a pretty heavy use of cringe in this
movie now normally what I've talked
about cringe in my severe distaste for
cringe it's been in the context of
cringe humor now it is being used to a
different effect here because the cringe
moments are being used to generate
tension as opposed to laughter but that
doesn't make it any more pleasant or you
know for me to have to watch I deeply to
my core dislike having to sit through
cringe moments in a film or a TV show
where you know you know that
everything's gonna go so badly for this
character and they don't seem to know or
they're powering through anyway it's
just it hurts me to watch and that's
true here and it's true and cringe
comedy so like things like that that was
just never gonna work with me and if you
don't have that issue with that kind of
material that's not gonna be an issue
for you with this film so woody let's
back up what even is this thing what is
he trying to do what is trying to be
what is it trying to say huh way more
difficult question to answer then it
should be I will come back to that it
really does seem to be borne out of the
pitch being what if Travis Bickle was
the Joker Travis Bickle is the
protagonist from taxi driver for any of
my younger viewers out there you know
what if the you know the guy in the
horrible city pushed to the point where
he takes drastic action ends up being a
super villain by the time he's done
that's pretty much the pitch and that's
very much the tone the visuals the vibe
it does appear to be a period film
everything in terms of the cars the guns
of technology everything is sort of
locked in late 70s early 80s including
the music cues and actually I will
single that out the music was clunky in
this
the it's very overbearing the score like
and it kicks in sooner than it needs to
there were a lot of moments that I think
would have landed a lot harder if there
hadn't been music behind them or or if
the music had kicked in after the moment
it happened or me even at the point that
the moment happened but they had this
real dark and Tony you know kind of
building ominous sound that it would
lead into the big moments and it didn't
help build them and it was kind of
intrusive but I didn't much care for
that and the music cues when songs come
in they don't feel like there was a lot
of thought put into them beyond oh this
is a song from the time period that
we're trying to evoke so we'll use that
and they're not completely off it's not
like whoa that doesn't fit it's more
like that that song choice doesn't
really do much to elevate this it's just
kind of there so you know that doesn't
do a lot for me before I get too far
into this because I I suspect I'm
probably gonna spend more time
complaining about this thing than
praising it so let me get this in there
right now
Joaquin Phoenix works his ass off in
this part he puts in a lot of work and I
honestly Joaquin Phoenix is not my
favorite actor but that probably has
more to do with the films he chooses to
do than his qualities that as an actor I
have never seen the man phone in a
performance ever when he when he takes
on a role he commits and he commits to
this pretty much everything that I can
say good about this is going to come
back to him I feel like he understands
this character better than the film
actually does but he is putting in a ton
of work in terms of physicality the
progression of the character getting
inside this character's head the vocal
delivery the texts it's all in all the
ways that Jared Leto's Joker was just a
collection of a fact Asians with no
purpose
everything has purpose in this
interpretation from Joaquin Phoenix
so like in many ways it is the absolute
antithesis of the jared leto Joker so
all the props to him he was stellar for
what they asked him to do he did great
the other featured actors are largely
pretty good as well Robert DeNiro
unfortunately the tail end of his time
he stuck with some very clunky on the
nose stuff but that's a spoiler a and B
deeper into my issues with the film so
we'll come back to that stick a pin in
it uh and then Francis Conroy's the
other major feature player as the
character of Arthur Fleck Joker
his mother played by Francis Conroy
who's always good that's another actor
I've never seen be bad in anything she
doesn't get apart nearly as showy as
Joaquin Phoenix does but she's very good
for what she is asked to do most of the
other supporting actors are fine there
really was nobody else that I recognized
which I think might actually be part of
the point I think it is supposed to feel
a little unstuck in time and not have a
bunch of recognizable actors at least I
think that might have been the intent
behind it but okay if I'm going to zero
in on this film and then I was onboard
or at least trying to be on board
through most of it but as it went along
I started to realize this movie knows
the tone it wants to set it knows you
know the the thing the things it wants
to evoke it doesn't actually seem to
know what it wants to say that's not to
say it's not saying anything I actually
think the movie might have worked better
if it had embraced the idea that had
nothing to say but my god I feel like
I'm getting ahead of myself okay let me
back up what is ultimately the story of
this movie
is it a story about mental illness
ignored by the system and by people
around it until it reaches a point where
it causes damage is it a story about
someone who feels so ignored for their
entire life and then they discover the
only way that they feel validated or
even that they exist is through violence
because that actually impacts the world
and people react is it a story about a
city gone mad and one man becoming the
embodiment of the anger and frustration
against everything that's going on in
that city the problem is the movie has
elements of all three and doesn't really
pick one to stick its flag in it's got
all this stuff going on and these aren't
like they're not mutually exclusive
ideas but if it was truly gonna have
something to say it needed to pick one
it needed to pick whether it was a story
about an ordinary man with nothing left
to lose who embrace who just snaps
someone who with mental illness who
reaches a point where he becomes what
maybe he always was but was trying to
hold back or it needed to be more
metaphorical where he is like an
embodiment of the sickness of the entire
city any one of those would have been
totally fine to really hammer home a
theme but it by dabbling in all three it
doesn't do any of them justice if it had
if it could have picked one or
alternately as I said like just decide
it's not gonna be anything it's not
gonna try and be deep at all and just be
exploitative and go for the more
visceral nature of the story which it
also has elements of that I think you
know you make people may or may not have
liked it but I think that would have
been a more valid focused way to go
about it
it's
again I feel like it doesn't have an
actual point it has a lot of things that
it kinda has something to say about has
a little bit to say about class
disparity it has a little bit to say
about mental illness it has a little bit
to say about forgotten populations but
it doesn't have a none of them is the
primary point none of them is the
primary focus and I'm not even gonna say
they had to abandon all of them and
select one but at the very least one of
these things had to be selected to be
the main point and then the others could
exist in support of it but since nothing
is primary nothing is in support of it
they just kind of exist in this nebulous
void around each other like in each
other's orbit but nothing is boosting
anything nothing is is amplifying a
purpose not and again I don't even think
the movie necessarily had to have a
purpose but it's presented like it
thinks it has one but it doesn't it has
multiple that it doesn't commit to and
alright so this is this the one bit of
outright spoilers I'm gonna get into so
my overall thoughts it's relatively well
made it thinks it's no it thinks that it
knows what it wants to be but it didn't
pick something specific enough at least
not for my perform I purposes
quacky Phoenix does great work he
commits like heck to this all the praise
in the world to him I'm gonna get into
spoilers to point out one last thing all
right I I don't want to dwell on this
because like I feel the entire
discussion is something that if I'm ever
gonna talk about I need to like devote
yet another video about it but if you
want some sense of where I'm coming from
on this I suppose you can check out my
video on joke telling from a little
while ago but Tom Phillips in recent
interviews has very much planted his
feet on the side of the people who say
society is to pee
see and it's ruined comedy in its
restricted art and he said things that
would appear to indicate that his
primary focus in even taking on this
project and directing this film was to
make people uncomfortable and to offend
people or to offend the people that he
thinks are too sensitive
my general stance on any piece of art
that offends and this is I'm being very
broad with this statement but I think it
is possible for anything any great piece
of work any meaningful piece of work to
be offensive being offensive neither
grants nor diminishes meaning of any
given piece and I think the best pieces
of work that are offensive are created
with a mentality of this is the thing
that I am going to make and I don't care
if it's offensive or not I'm not going
to alter what I'm trying to do because
I'm worried about whether or not you
will be offended
so offense is not the point offense is a
byproduct cuz you're focused on what
you're trying to do the mentality that
Todd Phillips again from the snip from
the things I've read from interviews
appears to be much more in line with
setting out going I want to offend
people and I don't think anything
meaningful comes out of doing that
because when you're when you have a goal
that happens to be offensive then you
can still have something important to
say if your goal is just to offend it's
not hard to offend people it's not hard
to be edgy that's really easy actually
and if that's your goal then you end up
with something really shallow because as
soon as you push it far enough that you
get the reaction you want you don't need
any more depth than that I think a great
example was the video game from what two
or three years ago hatred this is black
and white video game all about being a
serial killer
it was a cry
game because every mentality and it was
just let's make this really offensive
game and it was a shallow game that
played like crap this movie is better
than hatred is a video game I like don't
overlook that comparison but like that's
that's the kind of thing that results
from the mentality of yeah I'm gonna
trigger some people today like know
figure out what you want to do do that
and if you make the decision that in
doing that you don't care if you offend
people cool but if you're going going
yeah
Stevie and handle this I just feel like
that results in something that just kind
of sits there and doesn't have a lot of
focus and point and I wouldn't even
dwell on this except there is a part of
the movie towards the very end and I
mentioned this when I brought up Robert
De Niro's part there's a bit of a it's
not a monologue but this back in your
mind as well be there was a back and
forth between Joker and this this
late-night talk show host played by
Robert De Niro that is just Robert De
Niro setting up this guy to be able to
rant and there's like there's one
segment and I'm gonna forget the exact
words so please forgive me but he says
you know it's you people and like he's
way out of the audience of this games of
not sorry not game shows list late-night
talk show but he's obviously also
pointing at the audience its you people
your system that says what we can a
can't do says what is or isn't funny and
that was so on the nose especially
alignment with some of the stuff Todd
Phillips has been saying lately and
honestly didn't fit anything else going
on in the film it just really gave the
game away in terms of the mentality
behind it from the director certainly
it's hard to say with the other folks
involved and Joaquin Phoenix's
performance is operating at a level
above just trying to be offensive he's
trying to do something I don't think
Todd Phillips was actually trying to do
anything beyond just here but you never
thought you'd see that and I'm not going
to get into I'd like I'm not even if
people want to have this conversation in
the comments do it respectfully I will
be watching but like I'm not even gonna
have the conversation about whether or
not it's like empowering to people you
know to be act out violently because
they feel ignored like I don't even want
to deal with that because if a film if
the film had picked a message along
those lines and committed to it maybe I
talked about that but it doesn't that
stuff just kind of in the periphery the
thing's not committed enough to feel
irresponsible as far as that whole end
of the conversation goes so I don't want
to deal with it beyond saying that what
this film is it is a waste of a really
committed performance from the lead
because I feel like the only person who
knew what they wanted this to be like on
a on an artistic level was Joaquin
Phoenix and everyone else is just kind
of there so yeah I'll leave it at that
Joker you see that what do you think
about it whatever your thoughts are
drops on me down in the comments let's
talk about a bunch of stuff you can do
you can support me on patreon if you
find me not too offensive did I trigger
you you can also check out my socials
I've got a book links all that stuff is
down in the description go ahead and
click on it links will take you places
hit the like to subscribe or don't you
don't have to because at the end of the
day you're the council I'm I'm just
running until next time this council is
it
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]